you ain't hurt me
no little bird I won't hurt you the rel
do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video today I want to pick
right back up where I left off in my
previous video about Sandor Clegane
in my last video I gave some predictions
for Sandor Clegane but I told you I had
another idea I wanted to say for today
because it also involves a few other
characters as of right now we really
don't know what the Hound will do next
season it seems obvious to me that he is
stowing the show for a reason but what
could that be most people including me
assume he will eventually fight and kill
his older brother gregor clegane next
season but what else can he do if he
survives that fight assuming the knight
King and Cersei are defeated what's next
for sand or clay game does anyone think
he would just ride off into the sunset
or does he have another part to play
obviously this all depends on whether or
not he survives all the battles that are
to come if he dies then you can't just
throw all of this out the damn window
but I happen to think he will live one
thing I can almost guarantee is we will
get to see Sandor Clegane arrive back in
Winterfell for the very first time since
the very first episode of the show not
only will we see him in Winterfell again
but we should also see a very similar
scene to when King Robert and his
entourage arrived at the Starks Castle a
few weeks ago Entertainment Weekly
released an article about the a season a
game of Thrones and in that article it
said at some point HBO will release a
proper final season trailer revealing
more until then here's some basic setup
we can tell you season 8 opens at
Winterfell with an episode that contains
plenty of callbacks to the show's pilot
instead of King Robert Baratheon's
procession arriving its Daenerys and her
army what follows is a thrilling intense
intermingling of characters some of whom
have never previously met and many who
have messy histories as they all prepare
to face the inevitable invasion of the
army of the Dead so as you can see when
Jon and Daenerys arrived with their
party it will
very similar to the scene when King
Robert Baratheon arrived in Winterfell
now what's interesting is Sandor Clegane
is one of the very few characters that
are still alive from King Robert's
procession as far as I remember the only
other characters that are still alive
are the three Lannister's Cersei Jaime
and Tyrion but even Tyrion wasn't in
King Robert's procession when he arrived
because Jaime had to go and find him
because he was already shacked up in
winter towns brothel when Sandor Clegane
gets to Winterfell with Jon and Daenerys
the show has a really good opportunity
to capitalize on some interesting scenes
as we all know Sandor Clegane has a
history with some of the stark children
as I mentioned in my last video his
reunion with Arya Stark should be great
that is something almost all of us are
dying to see but his reunion was Sansa
Stark could be even more interesting for
a few other reasons which I want to get
into today for those of you that don't
know there is a very popular theory that
is known throughout the game of Thrones
and A Song of Ice and Fire fandom and
this theory is known as the Sansan
theory now before any of you jump to
conclusions my video is not necessarily
about that theory but I do want to
reference it to add some more context to
a different idea I want to propose today
if you don't know sansan stands for
Sansa and Sandor just to sum up the
sansan theory it basically states these
two characters end up together in the
end now I don't know if these two
characters will end up becoming
romantically involved or not but I do
think Sandor Clegane can remain by songs
aside in my last video I told you I had
one other prediction for Sandor Clegane
but it did also involve a couple other
characters which are Sansa Arya and
Brienne of Tarth obviously all of these
characters would have to survive until
the very end now I know that might seem
unlikely but you have to remember in the
television show Sandor Clegane Arya
Stark and Brienne of Tarth are some of
the best fighters so I don't think it's
too crazy to think that they could live
until the end now I know this might seem
like a crazy idea but what if Sandor
Clegane Arya Stark and Brienne of Tarth
become Sansa Starks Queen's Guard before
you disregard this just hear me out for
a few seconds now when it comes to Sansa
there is still a very good chance she
could become the queen maybe not the
queen of Westeros but she could become
the queen in the north at the very least
when you think about it she is basically
the
in the north already even if she doesn't
actually have that title as we all know
Cersei Lannister currently sits on the
Iron Throne but Daenerys wants to take
her place however we all know Jon Snow
is deter heir to the Iron Throne
so things get a little complicated when
it comes to who should be controlling
Westeros the crazy thing is there might
not even be an Iron Throne by the end of
the show the kingdoms may be split up
into their own sections so they can have
their own independence
if that happens Sansa might remain as
the lady in Winterfell or the Queen in
the north however you want to look at it
even if Jon Snow is alive by the end of
the show once he finds out he is a
Targaryen I highly doubt that he would
want to take over in the North when he
knows one of the Starks should remain in
power at Winterfell
since Arya and Bryan already have their
own parts to play then that would mean
Sansa would remain in her position in my
opinion now if we go back to the first
season of the show they were setting up
Sansa to become the Queen very early on
in the story
Sansa even said that she would become
the Queen over and over again you left
your home to come here and I'd be Queen
someday
it's beautiful like the one your mother
wears you'll be queen Sunday it's only
fitting you should look the part who
knows what treasons she may hatch no
I'll be a good wife to him you'll see
I'll be a queen just like you I promise
I won't hatch anything now I know songs
I was thinking about this because she
was supposed to marry Joffrey and become
his queen but as we all know that never
happened
Joffrey ended up getting married to
Margaery then Joffrey died at that
wedding however that doesn't mean Sansa
still can't become the Queen maybe all
of those references were foreshadowing
what would happen to Sansa at the end of
the story
just look at the position songs as in
she has finally found herself in a very
high position of power and as we all
know she has learned from some of the
very best players in the game
Littlefinger in Cersei songs as life
experiences have shaped her into the
woman that she is today and hopefully
that makes her a good Queen assuming she
doesn't die now when it comes to Sandor
Arya and Brienne becoming songs as
Queen's Guard let's just take a look at
some of the other things that have been
said in the show Brienne of Tarth
basically already has that job as we
speak
she already swore an oath to protect
Sansa so if songs have becomes Queen it
would almost be natural for Brienne to
become a member of her Queen's Guard
lady Sansa I offered my services once
again I'm shield your back and keep your
counsel and give my life for yours if
need be I swear it by the old gods Ning
you also don't forget Brienne was a
member of Renly Baratheon's Kingsguard
already so this will not be the first
time we have seen a woman take that
position your grace I ask the honor of a
place in your Kingsguard
I will be one of your seven pledge my
life to yours and keep you safe from all
harm
[Music]
this would actually be the second time
Berean has done this now when it comes
to sandor clegane this one might be a
little harder for some people to get on
board with especially if you think the
Saints and theory is completely out of
the question like I said I don't really
know if they will become romantically
involved or not but we do know that the
hound has no problem with protecting
Sansa he even told her Sansa would
become the queen and he would be our
guard killings the sweetest thing there
is why are you always so hateful you'll
be glad of the hateful things I do
someday when you're Queen and I'm all
that stands between you and your beloved
king now I know that was another
reference to Sansa and Joffrey getting
married but that doesn't mean it can't
happen in the future
Sansa is now in power in the north and
the Hound is on his way there so who
knows how things end up in the end now
when it comes to Arya Stark
let's take a look at a few very
important scenes with Arya and her
father Ned Stark listen to what Arya
says in the scene about our brother bran
Stark now the bronze awaits will he come
live with us well he needs to get his
strength back first he wants to be nice
of the Kingsguard he can't be one now
can he no as you can see Arya says that
our brother Bryan wanted to become a
member of the Kingsguard
but since brain was injured that can no
longer happen but as we all know Arya
has always wanted to do the things that
her brothers were able to do she never
wanted to become a lady she would rather
kick some ass since Bryan never got to
become a member of the Kingsguard
maybe Arya can take his place and what
would be more fitting than Arya
protecting Sansa this is something else
that Ned made sure to remind Arya of in
the first season you're a stark of
Winterfell
you know her words
winter is coming you were born in the
long summer you've never known anything
else but now winter is truly coming and
in the winter we must protect ourselves
look after one another
Sansa is your sister I don't hate her
now that winter is truly coming the
Starks have to stick together and
protect one another she should not be
fighting against her sister she should
be fighting with her sister as a team
Orion ever forgot that because almost
the exact same sentiment was repeated
when Arya and Sansa took down
Littlefinger together in winter we must
protect ourselves look after one another
[Music]
and the snows fall and the white winds
blow the lone wolf dies at the PAC's
Sansa follows that up by saying the lone
wolf dies but the pack survives songs
and arias relationship may become even
closer from here on out and if Sansa
does become the official queen she will
need protection can you imagine if songs
as Queen's Guard consisted of Sandor
Arya and Brienne of Tarth that would be
impressive especially when you consider
what happened during this scene Brienne
and a hound nearly killed each other
then Aria left him for dead but in a
crazy turn of events all of them are now
on the same damn team let me know what
you think about this idea I'm not saying
it's a guarantee or anything like that
but it was just an idea that I had that
I wanted to discuss it gives us
something a little different to think
about until the final season finally
airs leave your thoughts or questions
down below in the comment section I want
to thank all of you for stopping by and
watching another video and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support my channel thank
you all very much
I hope you have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
you